dude that move right there i can't
believe they didn't do it with wires
there is a i don't know 10 story drop
right there
and it's real glass so you might slip
and go off the balcony this is by far
one of the scariest things i've ever
done wow
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around to see how you can
get 15 off your order hi welcome back to
another episode of stuntman react we're
joined here by our friend jesse laflaire
now i'm doing something a little bit
different for this episode rather than
focusing on big explosions or squibs or
other like getting hit by cars all kind
of stuff we are focused on the art of
movement because jesse is a parkour and
free running master yeah i'm super
stoked life's been great man i've been
referred to as the tony hawk of parkour
if you want to say that
i mean i've directed films i've won
awards around movement and parkour
besides that i've made a career in the
stunt industry i'm really excited for
this episode this is me this would be
good
yeah seriously
[Music]
if you if you aren't aware this is
sebastian fukan he's the actor playing
the bad guy right now he's kind of
coined as being the creator of free
running the extension of parkour him and
david bell the original creator and
what's crazy is this scene alone like
did so much for the public kind of
knowing what parkour was because they
did a ton of marketing of having
sebastian like talk about free running
and movement
dang like that whoa this looks crazy
it's got to be on a wire then yeah but
this
i don't know this plyo feels so like
whoa yeah maybe he's on the wire and
we're just seeing the tail end of the uh
the shot here right where he's still in
the wires catching him we're starting to
catch him right here he's slowing down
and like
he's swinging into it a little bit
there's no way he's not on a wire for
that it's such a huge i mean it's such a
fantastic
it's like a little thing on top of that
elevator that's so cool no it's gone no
it's gone yeah you know i'm not gonna
lie having a wire and being able to
practice moves like that would be kind
of cool yeah think about every show you
work on you most of the time we're
working with the team you've never
worked with before so it's like your
life is literally you know how to do
wires yeah it's what i do for a living i
don't know if that's true
oh my god
[Music]
that's pretty crazy right there that no
wires wires you know there's a lot of
safety wires in this you can find some
behind the scenes stuff
murders that work yeah it's like don't
come up here and say ah
get out of my way i mean there's not a
lot of running space he had to clear his
path and make an explosion
once again you're all evil workers
sometimes in stunts you get to do fun
stuff like this was probably so fun just
to ride this little accelerator up like
this has been working so hard
on this new hospital that they're
building and james bond just comes in
and messes it all up
this this is very interesting so jumping
to this
again i know he's on a line for his
safety of falling but it doesn't look
like it was an assisted jump
oh and clearly his feet miss his hands
grab really nicely but they might have
had the line so like what they tend to
do is so the line will be extended to
the exact end mark where it needs to go
so regardless of what happens he's not
falling through
i love how this this whole scene just
gets sketchier and yeah let's just go
higher too why not just keep going
sebastian obviously not a fight guy but
worked a ton with the stunt team to try
to get some good choreography going
[Music]
that fall right there is that amazing
the fact he like catches himself
backwards yeah goodness
oh this was so sick wow
dude that is awesome yeah and i don't
know i've not seen anything that looked
like he had wires for that it's so
smooth it goes by so quick you like
these those are definitely yeah
[Applause]
i don't even want to talk about it
actually part of what i was going to
write in the email about coming on and
being a part of the show was that you
couldn't show the scene
dude that move right there i can't
believe they didn't do it with wires
[Laughter]
when this came out this was still like
early this was like beginning a youtube
days like
no one was really talking about what
parkour was so then all of a sudden this
is what people think parkour is dude
this is so funny
so he says gainer from that into from
the pallets into the trash can
how difficult that is you know
ridiculous that is yeah
all right so this scene has
single-handedly put parkour as a word
into millions of people's mouths gave
them a slight understanding of kind of
what it is we do
while at the same time ruining our
reputation
pretty much forever so like you know the
skateboarders will get like do a kick
flip and do a kick we'll also get the do
a back flip but what we'll get the most
is parkour and then people will just do
this
unofficially i think this is the world
record for the longest parkour or foot
chase scene in television history [ __ ]
yeah is that you
[Laughter]
so what what is your secret to not just
like breaking your ankles when you're
jumping for more than six feet in the
air well i wear the leflare pro model
shoe
oh there is it right there look at these
things look at these things we did go
into pads on that and they did i mean
great job editing three different air
jumps you know it's the same jump three
different angles so you get that like
hang time yeah which i love because
that's what it feels like for us when we
jump off something really high is like
it feels like you're just flying that's
why i love it
[Music]
all right so first things first did they
shatter that window before you hit it or
did you break that so this is my this
was my first like going through glass
literally the first time i ever did it
and the stunt guys on set are telling me
the story is like well here's the deal
there's gonna be a guy he's special
effects he's got a popper so it'll pop
the glass so when you go through it
you'll go through it fast so if you go
too hard there is a i don't know 10
story drop right there
and it's real glass so you might slip
and go off the balcony and there's no
safety device right
so i'm just like okay here we go you
know your favorite frame here doom see
it comes from the bottom corners and
then i'm pretty much through it oh you
even got a gopro angle on this
little ninja warrior for you
damn heck yeah do you have stairs in
your house do you have a metal
this was pretty gnarly too that's a lot
of air in my stunt rail if you look past
this edge on the left side it's just
death drop they had no safety mats or
anything first off the roof i'm coming
off of literally you're in hawaii it
rains all the time so the roof pebbles
wet the wall we tried you can probably
see a little bit of the whiteness on it
we did a little bit of tack spray we
looked at it i was like this would be
incredible and they let me design so
much of it like this i was like i want
to get a double kong off of rails over a
drop like a sketch man i want to build
that into television where people can be
like damn parkour's cool
you want a wire there no no wire there
no wire here wow if you missed it there
was just a gopro in my mouth
i literally ran up this thing probably
ten times nine of those times was
without a gopro
this is the point where we asked for a
subscription i'm not gonna ask you to
subscribe i'm just gonna know that if
you like our content you'll make the
right call
before we rolled here you're talking
about the moment between three two one
and action you as a as a person as a
human everything you've ever been
designed to do is to save yourself don't
hurt your head don't hurt your body
right in stunts yes you're you learn how
to fall safely but a lot of times
there's still this you're gonna get hurt
you're gonna have bruises you can break
something like i'm not addicted to
adrenaline but i'm addicted to this
moment of like letting go and somewhere
in between one in action you have this
like there's just like you shut it off
okay i need to hit this this is by far
one of the scariest things i've ever
done right
oh wow
wow
so this is the craziest part about this
stunt i can't practice it the step-up's
like about it's a little bit more than
hip height i think slight angle up
almost in line with the top of the roof
so i need to like judge the distance get
the speed step up high enough the fact
that it worked i was so stoked because
you could see i'm like coming straight
for it and i just all my momentum dies
right at that right moment dang
oh he had to do it too i do need to
mention that the stunt double who's
chasing me they have this super
realistic silicone face of the actor
yeah that the stunt double wears the
more you describe this the more insane
the stunting like this is yeah it's so
sketchy like are there any pads above
this like out in my stunt rail i have a
an outside shot of it that you can see i
believe you can see that there are pads
on the ground you have to nail it
perfectly like if not you're going to
clip your head or you're going to clip
your feet are you scared or nervous like
doing that move i mean that was yeah
that was a big one for me in terms of
self-trust
and just like knowing and trusting that
the skills and years of practice i've
had would protect me that was probably
one of those the most sort of
interconnected psyche ones guys i need
help with some jackie chan clips here so
if you have an awesome jackie chan clip
that you would like for us to break down
with professional leave a comment down
below we read them all it's a good time
you remember the uh that one scene where
jackie chan jumps off the top of the bus
and he's supposed to jump through a sign
and he jumped through the wrong sign he
literally jumped through an actual sign
i did not know that
[Music]
oh
my god dude so he picked the wrong side
supposed to be the further panel on that
sign they jump through the wrong panel
oh
real glass right there i mean that's
gnarly too because you're obviously yeah
he's all caught up you're moving like
along it so even i know your momentum
that's breaking the glass you're
essentially breaking through and then
the shards are you're going into the
shards yeah well the question is why
does that happen right like how could
that have happened there's just so many
moving parts to not only his sequences
but production itself so like
miscommunication or just being in the
moment at the wrong time and just
committing oh that's the one having
those nerves be like go go go you don't
want to miss it what three letters was i
supposed to jump through
[Laughter]
guys hey jake back here thank you all
for watching my stunt reel last time my
trainer wesley and i are here today uh
because i wanted to give you guys an
update um i haven't gotten any jobs
except for the one the pre-the birthday
party i think yeah if i train to be a
parkour master i'll probably get more
jobs the best way to train for parkour
is by using premium wireless bluetooth
earbuds so courtesy of today's sponsor
raycon wes is going to be in my ear
giving me a constant stream of
motivation from a a separate location to
not get in the way of my
okay let me put these in my ears and
we're going to get started so let's go
ahead and pop these in
you see that that's a that's a charging
case that gives you over six hours of
play time when you're done using them
you just pop them back in here they
recharge let's let's get started jake
can you hear me
let me see the patty cake unlaced wall
worn
inverted cheetah over the railing
you're doing great i love everything
you're doing you know most people go
about life every day and all they do is
walk the path before them you might see
a hill i see a slide you might see a car
i see leapfrog you might see a wall
you see a doorway i see a doorway the
first thing you guys will notice about
raycon is that they sound just as good
or better as any other premium wireless
earbud on the market but they start at
about half the price their e25 is one of
the best yet with over six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass and a more compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating fit
they also come in all your favorite
colors and pairings and if you use the
link in the description below you'll get
15 percent off your purchase that's just
buy rakon.com corridor crew and you'll
get 15 off your purchase
what is that dude that's not parkour
what that is parkour is it not parkour
it is it is totally parkour that is not
that's my classic parkour are you
kidding me he just flipped a cone and i
flipped the cone this is this is more of
an obstacle for him to do his parkour
and as he lands the you know what jake
where do you find this guy so listen to
this guy behind the camera he's a
complete stranger okay so if you guys
are sick of overpaying for earbuds or
having earbuds that have donglies or
don't pair with your phone or what have
you consider raycon they are one of the
best on the market and i guarantee you
you'll be happy that you did
honestly that was really great that was
very special i'm glad that you were able
to do this with us and like a parkour
episode makes so much sense and i'm so
glad we got you of all people to be here
for this
if you guys want to check out more of
jesse's stuff he's got a youtube channel
yeah if you guys want to learn any
parkour i definitely have a ranged
beginner intermediate and advanced
movements that's under la flair parkour
if you just want to see him do cool
stuff you can follow him on instagram at
jesse leflare i mean he's on all the
social medias i said you know feel free
to send them a question or something
like that
hit me up see in the dms